we have treatments of mice that work
extremely well and there's no reason why
that wouldn't work in people if we
worked hard enough at it by identifying
an area the hippocampus or the brain
that's really linked to aging and now
with this study finding a specific
specific molecular pathway we could
begin thinking of interventions that can
really ameliorate normal age-related
memory loss I was a very surprised to
see that when I increase the levels of
this protein specifically the dentate
gyrus of aged wild-type mice to see the
memory performance of these mice to get
better and actually to be comparable
with the young mice and did expect that
that was a surprising finding the point
here is that we now have a molecular
measure or lure with which we can now
assess all these interventions whether
it's what we eat how we behave or even a
pharmaceutical agent I think this paper
provides further and most compelling
evidence so far that age-related memory
loss is distinct from Alzheimer's
disease that we've identified at least
one molecular pathway that is critically
involved based not only in the current
study which is the most convincing but
earlier studies this really sets the
stage for developing better diagnostics
and better interventions to try to
ameliorate age-related memory decline
versus alzheimers disease